if animators get lazy overburdened or
careless then cgi can totally ruin
what's happening in a movie
but some of these animated mishaps are
hard to spot so today we're looking at
everything from marvel movies to sci-fi
masterpieces
as we discover the cgi mistakes that you
might have missed
the marvel cinematic universe gave us 21
movies leading up to the epic conclusion
that is avengers endgame in a movie
teeming with an enormous amount of cgi
it's a testament to the acting
capabilities of the incredible cast that
they're able to portray the necessary
emotions
while staring up into the giant foam
heads of cgi character standards
of course given that these movies have
such a large fan base
it stands to reason that slip ups would
be noticed as fanatics hover with their
noses
inches from the screen pen and legal pad
at the ready
some of these mistakes are so miniscule
they're hardly worth mentioning at all
such as a rendering issue in one of
thanos legendary finger snaps where his
fingers ever so slightly pop out of his
glove
others however could lead us to miss out
on several seconds of action
as we scratch our heads a prime example
of this would be in the climactic moment
when mjolnir finds its way into the
hands of captain america
seconds before this thados is pushing
the axe stormbreaker into thor's chest
while the god of thunder resists with
all of his might it's at this moment
that the legendary hammer zips through
the air and clips thanos's shoulder
a second after the hit thanos turns back
to face her star-spangled attacker
and he's no longer holding the axe but
instead he's wielding his dual bladed
sword
an unfortunate oversight are you crying
no yes
released in 2011 in time stars justin
timberlake and brings to life a
dystopian future
in which time has been monetized in this
sci-fi flick all humans have been
engineered to stop aging at 25
and they've been given a timer on their
forearms that constantly counts down
if this timer reaches zero you die
instantly
so of course the primary currency of
this world is time itself
bet you 50 years sure it's an obvious
metaphor but an intriguing plot
nonetheless
most of the film takes place in a
visibly believable landscape that
doesn't need to implement an excessive
amount of cgi
there is one scene however that used it
with terrible results the main
characters are making a getaway in a
stylish sports car when they drive
across road spikes the spikes blow out
their tyres
and send the car careening off the road
tumbling down a rocky hill
suddenly the car turns on cgi and it's
bad
real bad adding insult to injury you can
see that the car is completely empty
no passengers are even inside as it
rolls down the hillside
the blunder is particularly frustrating
because the use of cgi doesn't even feel
necessary
and it seems like this should have been
an easy mistake to fix as they could
have just added dummy passengers and
editing
in the early 2000s cgi was lacking in
many departments
granted most of the time were able to
overlook a lot for nostalgia's sake
but some mistakes from the period seem
avoidable as if they merely came down to
a lack of oversight
and it's especially worse when you
inject a copious amount of bad animation
into a scene
that's supposed to be slow and
sentimental it really kills the mood
one of the worst offenders here is star
wars episode 2 attack of the clones
particularly that cheesy scene i don't
like sand
no not that one the other one from the
moment i met you
all those years ago not a day has gone
by when i even thought of you
yeah you know what let's just come out
and say it it's this scene the dinner
scene where anakin and padme are having
a
romantic meal together specifically the
moment when anakin sends a piece of pear
floating across the table using his
powers
moments before delivering the piece of
the fruit to padme with the force
the cgi is obvious as he cuts into it
once a piece of floating fruit reaches
padme
she plugs it out of the air using a fork
and takes a bite however the bite
doesn't even register on the fruit until
after she pulls back from the fork
the scene itself feels unnecessary and
comes across more as george lucas
trying to show off his company's
technical wizardry
however you felt about the adaptation of
shazam it's hard to argue that a 14 year
old's first stop with this new
superpowers would be to stock up on
cheetos and red bull
having your jerky if you eat enough of
it it can burn a hole in your stomach
worth it yeah most of the action
sequences in their superhero flick
maintain a fun visual aesthetic that
doesn't have us rolling our eyes too
much there is however one glaringly
obvious slip up in one of its most
iconic fight scenes in his first battle
with the villainous dr savannah
billy struggles to fully utilize his
powers stumbling through a mall as he
tries to master the power of flight
there is a particular sequence where our
hero is jogging through the air by an
escalator
as panicked bystanders scramble to
escape the mayhem
but if you pay attention to the
background you can see several crew
members
complete with set passes around their
necks along the right side of the frame
they stand almost statuesque quietly
observing as everyone around them
sprints around the mall
director david f sandberg stated that it
was a mistake they caught later on in
post-production
they tried correcting it by adding cgi
shopping bags to make it seem as though
the crew members were shoppers in the
mall
it was a valiant effort but a quick
rewatch shows the mistake is still
apparent
watchmen 2009's dark gritty adaptation
of alan moore and dave gibbons graphic
novel
is still the source of much debate among
superhero fans
some lord it for its accuracy to the
source material but others dismissed it
as a hackneyed attempt by director zack
snyder
to once again capture lightning in a
bottle after the success of 300. the
movie takes place in an alternate
reality filled with superheroes who tend
to be a product of their environment
some of them are overly self-righteous
others are a bit kooky
but none are as powerful as the glowing
super being known as dr manhattan
played by billy crudup we repeat the
superman exists
and he is american most of crude
obscenes as dr manhattan were the actor
in a full motion body capture suit
complete with 2 500 glowing blue bulbs
the cgi of the character itself was
quite magnificent even somehow escaping
the dead eyes that can plague some
animation
which was quite a feat given that the
hero's eyes are just glowing white
eyeballs but even the most thorough
animator can slip up from time to time
in one of the final scenes as a
villainous aussie mandios is confronted
by other heroes there are several
moments when you can see dr manhattan in
the reflection of night owl's goggles
only it isn't a cgi rendered dr
manhattan it's billy crudup in his light
up onesie
the mistake may be small but it's still
one that will consume you the next time
you watch the watchmen
the matrix opened our eyes to all the
possibilities that computers hold for
our future
like everyone else you were born into
bondage born
into a prison that you cannot smell or
taste or touch
over 20 years later most of the movie
holds up well
and it's still fun to tumble down the
rabbit hole with morpheus however while
neo might be a messiah the movie itself
isn't flawless
in fact there's one scene in particular
that contains a cgi blunder
and it's the moments that matrix fans
have seen many many times
in the climactic moments of the film neo
and trinity are on the rooftop of a
skyscraper
on route to rescue their beloved leader
morpheus and that's when one of the
sinister agents takes over the body of a
helicopter pilot
and confronts our hero neo unloads the
rest of his bullets to the agent
who dodges every single one neo chucks
his now md guns aside
as the agent raises his own pistol and
takes aim no doubt you know what happens
next
but what you probably haven't noticed is
everything that's disappeared as a
camera pant around the bullet dodging
neo
the bodies of most of the swat officers
they had just thought all vanish
along with trinity herself and the md
guns neo chucked aside
given how long ago in cgi's history the
matrix was released
and how iconic the movie is in pop
culture it's easy to forgive this
mistake
but it doesn't make it any less easy to
ignore as the camera pans around 360
degrees of nearly empty space
it's hard not to love everyone's
favorite museum wolverine he was brought
to life by hugh jackman who played the
superhero for 17 years
before wrapping up his final appearance
as the gruff regenerating hero
in the wonderful logan but while he
appeared in several x-men movies
jackman's first dive into wolverine's
background came in the 2009 film x-men
origins wolverine
unfortunately for the movie we're
willing to watch it thanks to our love
for jackman
because i'm the best there is of what i
do what i do best
isn't very nice but the filmmaking
itself it's pretty rough
especially those subpar cgi effects a
lot of the action scenes are still fun
and like it or not
we even get a glimpse of ryan reynolds
alternate version of deadpool but when
you slow a scene down and try to get all
contemplative
it can be hard to disguise a lack of cgi
quality early on in the movie
logan is in the bathroom examining his
claws and it's painfully obvious these
blades animated as they fail to twist
and turn
with the movements of jackman's fists
given that they aren't sparking against
concrete or clashing with deadpool's
ridiculous sword claws
it's hard not to stare obviously there's
plenty of computer-generated imagery in
the harry potter series
after all this is a movie about wizards
and you need some animation to make all
their spells come to life
but with all that cgi magic happening on
screen there are bound to be a few
mistakes here and there
you may have giggled at the clumsy
computer-generated bathroom troll in the
sorcerer's stone
but that fiasco was simply a product of
its time another huge cgi era in the
series is more of an oversight that
probably slipped by without you even
noticing
in the prisoner of azkaban we met and
fell in love with gary oldman's
misunderstood serious black
and once the film was exhausted all our
emotional capabilities
we wind down with harry and sirius for a
heartfelt moment
the ones that love us never really leave
us black then hops onto a hippogriff and
flies up into the night
in the shot where the hippogriff takes
off the ground underneath him is
completely clear of any clutter
so clear in fact that it shines with the
reflection of the moon a quick moment
later
harry and hermione run across the same
ground and is cluttered with leaves and
debris
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one